a lot of people think I'm confident but
I'm actually just loud
yeah when it comes to believing in
myself I'm an atheist
I don't have any wealthy friends but I
do have some friends with wealthy
boyfriends so that counts for something
um yeah a lot of my friends are actually
dating older guys
yeah how old you ask
my best friend got asto via email
[Laughter]
girls out here getting sent dick pics as
attachments
some of my friends don't even like send
me screenshots of their messages with
guys anymore they just BCC me
pumped because this Sunday we're
celebrating International women's day
y'all
don't worry you don't have to remember
to go out and get anyone flowers you
just have to remember to go out and
fight for equal pay for women in the
workplace yeah
now I know there are guys out there
thinking International women's day why
don't we have an international men's day
well you're in luck because you do it's
actually on November 19th but you
wouldn't know that because you're too
busy celebrating it every other day of
the year
also fun fact November 19th is also
International toilet day
no I'm not I'm not saying men are
toilets but
both holidays are mostly catered towards
a bunch of white Johns
the hard part is that
we've scared men out of making basic
decisions which to me is the sexiest
thing a man can do I have to say I think
the sexiest thing a man can do is make a
plan
just got so relaxed first
[Applause]
right
uh
it's so hot
look at the reason all the men are like
well I didn't plan to come here I don't
know
yeah she said put on a clean chair we're
going to the comedy is that plan
like we're so excited to go out with you
and then right before the day we'll get
a text that's like where do you want to
eat God
like
like you're paying for it like I don't
know what your financial background is
so I don't know if John asked if anybody
celebrating anything tonight but I know
that I don't care because I have
something really big going on you guys I
finally just slept with my high school
Crush
right that's exciting right thank you
thank you but now he like expects me to
go to his graduation
I know what I'm gonna be doing in three
years right oh
kids these days I don't know
I don't know
no I would never [__] a kid that's weird
right and I would never I shouldn't say
never that's stupid what if the right
one comes along I'm gonna not
do it because I told you strangers no
I'm gonna [__] that kid so
so my mom's a [__] uh
so she's always bragging about the
dumbest stuff the other day she's like I
can still fit in my wedding dress like
who cares right I mean it is weird that
she's the same size now as she was when
she was eight months pregnant but I
don't know
why brag right I don't see it but
I don't know I don't want a baby I see
him they're around they're running
around I'm like keep it moving keep it
moving
not interested I'm supposed to I'm 30.
I'm supposed to want to make something
with my body but I'm like no I think
it's because this is what I do for a
living I get drunk every night
I'm drunk now uh
but the girls I grew up with you know
they're living normal adult lives so
they call me and they're like aim I'm
pregnant and I'm still like what are you
gonna do
like no they're like [__] we're 30.
like what
I'm like I'll drive you shh
this is like the most good looking crowd
ever this is not good for my self-esteem
Don't Clap for yourself some people say
yes we are gorgeous
we are gorgeous well you know I know
what it's like we judge each other right
like I walk out here and right away you
guys are thinking like oh my God like
she's so [__] pretty
um
[__] you
wow that's really sweet of you guys
a little Pilates nothing big but I uh
why is it 2022
and you still need two remotes so
another TV
and if it's not your TV and look at
those remotes it's like Russian roulette
with the heavens
where you're like if I get the wrong
thing I'm gonna have to be stuck with
the thoughts in my head all day I don't
want that at all men are Hunters women
are gatherers these are your societal
roles as dictated by nature men are
Hunters women are gatherers
except for when it comes to shopping
and then women are Hunters but we are
the only creatures that will rationalize
a kill after we make it
a lion runs down a turkey eats it don't
think twice about it although why align
and turkey are on the same terrain I
don't know this isn't a matter no
woman's ever just swiped a credit card
but like super confident with myself and
that choice I'm just gonna go no
[Applause]
no
there is a full-on debate between that
girl and whatever poor soul she dragged
with her that day to the mall it's like
was that a good idea those shoes are
super cute do you like them I really
like them are you sure you like them
they're really cute are you sure
usually better for five hours you want
to go home to my family I have a friend
who is 26 and he's a virgin which that
she's like
yeah no that's fine though right yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you're like
very quiet support from my friend but um
it is fine I tell him that all the time
I'm like hey it's fine like stop yelling
right it's okay
but he gets very upset he hates it very
much right because he's trying a lot but
like I feel bad for him and I want him
to be happy right because he's my friend
you know you guys care about your
friends and so we made a pact like we
have one of those like classic
agreements right where if by the time we
both turn 40 right and he's still a
virgin and yeah and I'm around right
like I
I will um kill him yeah
I'm an alcoholic I don't know if that's
reading
um a little bit I have a very helpful
tattoo it says don't serve me on my arm
it's okay bartenders can't read cursive
Pablo Picasso Harvey Weinstein Bill
Cosby Woody Allen Roman Polanski
these men are not exceptions they are
the rule and they're not individuals
they are our stories and the moral of
our story is we don't give a [__] we
don't give a [__] about women or
children we only care about a man's
reputation
what about his Humanity
these men control our stories and yet
they have a diminishing connection to
their own humanity and we don't seem to
mind so long as they get to hold on to
their precious reputation
[__] reputation hindsight is a gift stop
wasting my time
if
I am angry
I apologize
I do I apologize on I know there's a few
people in the room are going ah look I
think I think she's lost control of
potential
that's correct on I need a bit there oh
uh so I'm not very experienced in in you
know controlling anger it's not my place
to be angry on a comedy stage I'm
supposed to be doing self-deprecating
humor
um people feel safer when men do the
angry comedy uh they're the kings of the
genre when I do it I'm just a miserable
lesbian ruining all the fun on the
banter when men do it Heroes of free
speech
I love I love Angry white man comedy or
oh so funny it's hilarious
they're adorable why
[Laughter]
why what's up little fella
what are they angry about gosh I can't
work it out they like the canaries in
the mine aren't they
if they're having a tough time
the rest of us are gone